holy [ __ ] Buffy the Vampire Slayer's
back kinda The Mortal Instruments City
of Bones I like saying bones like that
spaces aren't creepier so the Mortal
Instruments city of it's pretty much a
straightforward movie there's this girl
she's different she knows she's
different because she's magical kind of
and this one dude named Jace who hunts
down demons he's Cumberbatch ish is what
I call him I'm a saint he's Cumberbatch
let's back up there I'm a total cumber
[ __ ] I didn't know that was a
tournament I am it's pathetic anyhow
this dude saves her ass and lets or no
though there's something different about
you you're kind of magical so come to my
big castle that's invisible in the
middle of New York we're going to find
out what's up and sure enough demons are
invading and then there are werewolves
and other magical creatures and pretty
much the world's gonna end or at least a
lot of bad things are going to happen
that's pretty much it it's a
straightforward movie you have magic and
demons and demon hunters and good versus
evil and you have some teen romance in
there because it's made for teenagers so
there you go throw it on the big screen
make a few bucks so it's easy to be like
super natural teen romance Twilight it
really did hold back on a lot of the
beat you over the head teen romance
gonna [ __ ] that Twilight has granted
there is teen romance in here for the
most part it's logical you know you got
this hot ass chick with these thigh high
boots and these short skirts and you're
like she's hot I think that this dude is
a badass who's a demon hunter who's
cumberbatch ish who saves her ass so you
know she's gonna want to bang him she's
hot so he's gonna want to bang her just
it makes sense it did annoy me at a
point though there's this one block of
time it's about 30 seconds when
everything goes kind of normal it is
sappy and shitty when the romance aspect
was because they're in this garden then
the sprinklers go off while they're
making out you're like is it now you
just have to simulate rain oh my god and
then her friend sees her with this J
stood and Jase is like oh I see how it
is and the guys like oh I see how it is
she's like well you know what you both
did with it and then the drama dude it
filled the frame it was not just like 30
seconds it went from sappy [ __ ] in a
supernatural story which I can I can
deal with to beat you over the head
middle school [ __ ] I was like what
this needs to end this needs to end
right now luckily for the most part it
ended but still I was like you okay if I
did stars this
movie would have lost a star right there
I don't do stars it's why I do phrase
writings
yeah the movies predictable as [ __ ] you
find out one ability someone has you're
like I know the next thing you're gonna
do I know where they're gonna go I know
where the thing that they're looking for
is and I know it's gonna happen when
they get there and you're right about
all of it mindless entertainment sure
good for teenagers yeah you want to kick
your feet up and be like alright let's
watch good versus evil here's what the
movie is it's like a lost two-hour
episode of Buffy the Vampire Slayer you
know the show from the 90s it does lack
the charm that Buffy the Vampire Slayer
had because Buffy was established over a
period of season in this movie have two
hours in and out and that's what you're
there for I do think it's a bit unfair
to say this movies copying Harry Potter
because it's really not I mean really
bear with me on this it just it has
magic yeah Harry Potter doesn't hold the
licence on magic really you can argue JK
Rowling with the Harry Potter series
ripped off the books of magic have you
read that really there's an owl you
should read it you could read that
you'll be like I don't know if Harry
Potter's as original as I really thought
it was crumbles your world it's it sucks
but Harry Potter is still awesome
because things are inspired by other
things but really just an author going I
can do something like that but put my
own spin on it here is a new story but
it is borrowed even Star Wars borrowed
from [ __ ] Dragonlance novels they were
inspired by Dungeons and Dragons you see
what I mean there's a ripoff Twilight
for 30 solid seconds it most definitely
does but for the most part the movie
didn't piss me off if you're a teenager
and you like this kind of stuff you want
to see some magic and good versus evil
go to the movie you'll probably have a
good time for people out there who need
more substance for their cinematic
palette I'd say pass on this but for me
I would say for what it was the Mortal
Instruments City of Bones is a good time
no alcohol required entertained me I'm a
big softy for magic [ __ ] I guess all
right so your favorite good versus evil
magic story of all time book movie video
game those count unless you say Harry
Potter the order of the Phoenix the
video game in which case no whatever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more